[Music]
what's up Barbara lights I'm Ryan fanaa
ghost aka agent damn and I am Jerry ray
games accessibility consultant streamer
and friend of Crystal Dynamics we are at
e3 to give fans worldwide a chance to
tour the epic Marvel's Avengers III
booth cherry I haven't seen anything
past what we see right here can we go
check it out let's go let's do it
Marvel's Avengers begins on a day with
Ironman Captain America Thor Black Widow
and a Hulk unveiling a high-tech new
avengers headquarters in San Francisco
including the reveal of a brand-new
Helicarrier powered by an experimental
power source the a3 booth is designed to
bring fans into the world of Marvel's
Avengers everything from the Dacor to
the badge is modeled after the in-game a
day experience you can find the booth in
the South Pole at number 1601 and if
you're here at e3 you gotta come get
your a day badge you're gonna get a
checkout time to come and see the
Marvel's Avengers demo 30 minutes of
Awesomeness
return to the booth during a designated
time slot to check out the official
Marvel's Avengers costume gallery before
journeying deeper into the Helicarrier
if you watch Marvel's Avengers III
trailer and we're sure you did you know
that the event turns deadly when a
catastrophic accident results in massive
devastation now the Avengers are blamed
for the tragedy and so they have to
disband but five years later the world
is in peril superheroes are outlawed
what's our only hope to reassemble
Earth's Mightiest Heroes cherry I loved
all these costumes I loved all this but
I want to go to the theater I gotta see
more you're I am so excited
when your time comes you'll be escorted
to an exclusive first gameplay demo for
Marvel's Avengers it will give you an
extended look at the explosive events of
a day and Intel on each of the Avengers
before leaving get your official aid a
lanyard and dossier as a souvenir of the
day that changed everything you can
learn more about Marvel's Avengers and
get information on the beta at play
Avengers dot-com Marvel's Avengers will
be available on ps4 xbox pc and stadia
on May 15 2020 we hope you enjoyed a
peek behind the scenes at e3 til next
time
I'm Ryan I'm Jerry this is Marvel your
universe